what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with the death of the Venom
verse we're covering the first three
issues in this video and this initially
opens up in an alternate reality
basically with what would normally be
the original origin of carnage which is
to say at some point in time Eddie Brock
and Cletus Cassidy were both in a jail
cell and the Venom symbiote broke Eddie
Brock out of jail and then in turn left
a little bit of itself behind which
basically became the Carnage symbiote
and then bonded itself to Cletus the
difference here is that the Carnage
symbiote emerges and then kills Eddie
Brock and then leaves Cletus behind so
what's going on here so for those of you
guys who have not been following Carnage
up to this point one thing to know is
that the Carnage symbiote does not have
a host at the moment that in the main
Marvel Universe it is normally bonded to
Cletus Cassidy but it's kind of out
there doing its own thing not only that
it's been consolidating a massive amount
of power so what it's doing now is
literally hopping through the Multiverse
and killing every version of Venom that
it can possibly find and so what this
does is this transitions to another
reality and we pick up with Anne
weighing from Earth 1051. now for those
of you guys who aren't familiar with
that Earth 1051 was a universe where
basically Eddie Brock's son Dylan and
there's a whole history behind this
which you can find the link to that
playlist at the end of this video that
Dylan Brock's son had effectively become
like this Uber symbiote and basically
killed all the superheroes on Earth and
then replaced them with symbiote
duplicates and comes from that reality
if she was one of the very last few
humans that was left alive that was
actually trying to work against Dylan in
that Universe ultimately he was defeated
and so what you have now is What's
called the Venom core if you want to
refer to it that way but essentially
they're on the hunt for Cletus across
the Multiverse so we're kind of picking
up in the middle of his murderous
Rampage across all of existence with
regards to these different Venoms and as
they're making their way through here
what we get is a kind of flashback
battle where you had Carnage facing off
against this reality's version of Laura
Kinney x-23 who had the Venom Symbian
and Carnage was able to take her out
with a quickness not only that there was
also an instance where Ant-Man in this
universe had also had the Venom symbiote
or potentially in an alternate reality
had the Venom Symbian and when that
happened of course the fight broke out
between himself and Carnage and Carnage
had killed Ant-Man and then went forward
from there so the question is why why
what's the motivation behind killing
these different versions of Venom well
one of the things that we've learned in
recent years in Marvel Comics is that
anytime anyone becomes a host for a
symbiote the Symbiote will leave behind
what's referred to as a codex kind of
like a genetic version of spray painting
Venom was here on that person's DNA but
the Codex is kind of like a source of
its power so when Carnage kills these
people who are hosts for the Venom
symbiote what he's doing in taking their
codex is he's expanding his own powers
he's growing his own abilities but he's
actually on the hunt for a few
particular things and we'll find out
what those are over the course of this
story now one of the things that we do
is we actually pick up with a character
named virus we will find out who he is
but at the start of this it's not who
you think it is and the reason I say
that is because the virus armor has
appeared in Marvel Comics before in
years past it belonged to Matt gargan
also known as the Scorpion but he's long
since lost it right there's actually
somebody else in the suit of armor one
of the reasons why you see like all the
Band-Aids and tape and stuff like that
is because the armor was basically
destroyed and now it's kind of been
recreated again but the forces of Anne
and her group are just like traveling
from one place to the next now this
takes us to a reality where Carnage
comes across Mania now Mania is a really
really cool character in Marvel in more
recent years she's a character named
scream who's also kind of like an
anti-venom character we'll talk about
what that means later on in the video
but in this reality she still simply
just Mania which is to say she's based
more off the Venom symbiote than the
Carnage Symbian now under any normal
circumstance this would not really be a
significant thing but as you guys will
notice there's this kind of Mark on the
chest of mania there's a reason she has
that and in fact it's actually going to
amplify Carnage's powers to a huge level
as time goes on and so what ends up
happening is that in the fight between
Carnage and Mania of course the forces
of and weighing show up and they do what
they can where they can but the reality
is that this is not simply just the
Carnage symbiote that we traditionally
know from the main Marvel Universe he's
way more powerful than he used to be and
so what they do is they kind of grab
Andy Benton right they grab Mania in
this alternate universe and then kind of
lure Carnage into a little bit of a trap
and when he gets to that location and
brings in the rest of her forces right
agent Spider-Man from Earth 1051 agent
Deadpool from 1051 and agent Hawkeye
from 1051. one of the things to realize
is there's no human element to these
guys they're all 100 symbiote right like
the human part is gone but the funny
thing here is that it's Child's Play for
Carnage to take these guys eyes out
that's just how powerful he is now he
takes these dudes out with the greatest
of ease but Mania ever The Reckless
character jumps in goes to fight Carnage
and is immediately killed and what that
does when he basically takes her codex
he also absorbs the artifact on her
chest which is a hellmark now the reason
why this matters is because in Marvel
Comics a hellmark is basically a mark
given to a person that could potentially
become a hell Lord at some point in the
future but it's most commonly bestowed
on people by Mephisto now does this mean
that you know essentially Carnage is now
Ghost Rider no but what it does mean is
that one of the three traditional
weaknesses that symbiotes have he's now
immune to the power of fire that he can
no longer be harmed by fire in any form
not only that because he has the
hellmark he can actually summon demons
which is pretty crazy right because
basically Carnage has become a hell Lord
now it's kind of nuts and so the only
thing they can really do is just like
get out of there as fast as they can
because now being able to channel the
power of fire he's way more of a match
for any of these symbiotes than he ever
was before and so that's when we get to
the second thing that Carnage is trying
to attain which is the ability to
manipulate electricity and this comes by
way of a reality that he ends up in
where you have what's known as the
Symbiote six in effect the Sinister Six
all of whom have been venomized right Dr
Octopus Craven the Hunter and Rhino and
of course Electro and so initially the
fight here is actually kind of
interesting in the sense that they keep
Carnage on the ropes just because
there's like six of them and one of
Carnage so even despite all the
abilities that he has facing off against
traditional villains is no small thing
because villains don't hold back the
same way that Heroes do and so because
of this it makes them incredibly deadly
to someone like Carnage but the funny
thing is that because of the power of
the hellmark he summons his own own
demonic forces that are able to go
against the Symbiote six and that's when
Anne's forces jump in because in
monitoring this entire conflict they
come to the realization this is one of
the best chances they would have right
that it'd be very easy and all the
distraction and all the chaos that
Carnage wouldn't necessarily be paying
attention and it would be relatively
easy to take him out in fact the exact
opposite happens that in all of this
chaos in pandemonium they underestimate
what Carnage is capable of and that by
using the full totality of his
symbiote's powers at this point in time
tendrils go in every direction and
virtually everybody is ripped to pieces
the only way that the forces of Anne
weighing are able to make it out in the
face of pretty much all the members of
the symbiote6 that are destroyed is that
one of them is able to use Sonics and
that when that happens it forces him to
retreat but not before he was able to
take the Codex of Electro which means
now the carnid Symbiote is immune to
electricity and he's immune to fire now
the question has to be yes why in the
world is he tracking down all these
different abilities right these
immunities well one we know that this is
leading to like a massive fight between
what is essentially the main Marvel
Universe version of Eddie Brock who's
kind of like the antithesis of the
beyonders he's this ridiculously
powerful character and like Carnage
itself but we're actually going to see
The Return of a very familiar face in
Marvel Comics which is a showdown for
the ages given like the level of power
that Carnage has know the Symbiote God
is coming back and it's gonna be dope
it's gonna be so amazing right some are
the Symbiotes man it's gonna be it's
just it's really really cool and so
following this of course with him
jumping into this new reality he ends up
coming across a fight between shriek and
a guy named chaos engine now chaos
engine is the one that actually has the
Venom symbiote shriek herself is similar
to the main Marvel Universe version but
the reality here is that the Carnage
that she recognizes here is not the
Carnage that she knows but she doesn't
recognize the difference that when you
have Carnage who shows up here and
weighing enter forces show up here yet
again now this is not designed to be
like some kind of time skip or anything
like that one of the things that's
happening is that as soon as carness
jumps to a different reality they
immediately chase after him because the
big concern here is that every single
time Carnage kills a Venom symbiote
whose Powers he can absorb he becomes
more powerful for the other symbiotes
that don't really have a level of power
that he's particularly chasing after
that in reality it's just him kind of
honing his fighting abilities but with
every Venom he kills he becomes stronger
so they're constantly chasing after this
guy there is no reprieve there's no
momentary break it's no like okay well
after this fight with Carnage let's all
go get dinner at The Sizzler that's not
what's Happening Here
and it's kind of cool to see because
even with the forces of Anne and the
fact that Rhino from The symbiote6 has
now joined Anne's forces if only to gain
revenge over his teammates that were
killed by Carnage the main goal of
Carnage here is to go after chaos engine
why because he has the ability to
manipulate Sonics and that in doing so
if he's able to overcome this guy kill
him and take his codex and his powers
then Carnage will be completely immune
to any and all forms of energy out there
outside of ultra high level reality
warping that could destroy him he'd be
immune to fire electricity and Sonic
right the three main weaknesses of any
particular Symbian such as it is Anne's
forces realize that if chaos engine does
have the ability to manipulate Sonics
protecting him at all costs is the most
important thing and that ultimately they
open a portal and they essentially jump
away and so because of this and starts
to realize that having Venom symbiotes
on their side is okay right it is a
pretty nifty thing to have but in
reality Carnage is just way more
powerful than they are so what she needs
is somebody out there that has the
ability to destroy Venom symbiotes what
she ends up doing is traveling to the
main Marvel Universe and going to find
Scream the main Marvel Universe version
of Andy Benton also known as anti-venom
because for those of you guys who are
not familiar with anti-venom in Marvel
Comics it's literally the antithesis of
Venom that anti-venom has the ability to
destroy any and all traces of the Venom
symbiote within any one particular
person not only that anti-venom has the
ability to like cure people of illnesses
for example like in the main Marvel
Comics anti-venom almost siphoned Peter
Parker's radioactive blood out of his
body right like cleaned him of his
spider powers that if it had been
successful he would have lost his
ability to be Spider-Man it was a pretty
nut story right it was awesome I'm
really glad we covered it right it was a
really really crazy story there but
following that right they kind of give
Andy Benton the whole rundown of
everything that's been happening up to
this point right like Carnage is
traveling through the Multiverse he's
trying to kill everyone you can come
across so he can destroy some Uber
villain out there or Uber character out
there they don't really know what his
main motivation is that he's basically
gained a whole host of powers and that
he is immune to most traditional
weaknesses of Symbiotes and that
anti-venom is really the only one that
they see as being able to help them
because she has the ability to shut down
the powers of any particular symbiote
that's out there what's so crazy is they
end up tracking Carnage to an alternate
universe where the war of Realms led to
the wholesale conquering of Earth now
the war of Realms was a story that was
done relatively recently in Marvel which
basically saw like the different Realms
that exist out there in Thor Mythos
right jotenheim and spartalheim and all
that kind of stuff that it was just like
a giant War among all those groups it
was led by a guy named malekith and that
he almost destroyed the entirety of
Earth he was ultimately stopped right
and the war of Realms Was Won by midgard
and the good guys and so on and so forth
in this universe it was a whole
different kettle of beans right like the
war of realms came to Earth and at the
end of the day Humanity survived but
Asgard now resides on Earth itself and
it's like the de facto governing body
now of course they're met by Valkyrie
which is not Jane Foster the valkyrie as
she exists right now it's actually the
daughter of brunhild the original
Valkyrie in Marvel Comics when I say
original I mean like original right like
the one who was on The Defenders way
back in like the 70s and 80s in Marvel
Comics like OG OG Valkyrie and Marvel
Bruno was cool right she was one of
those super underrated characters but of
course as you would expect in the middle
of all this Carnage shows up
and Garnet starts attacking everybody
and that chaos engine is one of like the
few people who can hold him at Bay by
firing off Sonic energy but lest we
forget yes Carnage is vulnerable to
Sonics but Carnage always learns after
every conflict he's engaged in which
means he knows how to Bob and weave and
Dodge the powers of chaos engine right
he's not immune to it but he does know
how to get around it and so that's kind
of the funny thing because what ends up
happening here is that Andy Benton
writes scream ends up manifesting and
bringing in other versions of Anti-Venom
and they initially go after Carnage and
for a moment it looks like she's gonna
get the upper hand because all she has
to do is touch him that's the only thing
she has to do what she doesn't realize
here is that he does not have a host so
there's nobody to suck any of this stuff
off of right like there's no one to
quote unquote cure that we don't know
exactly what would happen if scream got
her hands on a symbiote with no host and
tried to cure it right try to basically
disincorporate it or eliminate it would
she successfully be able to destroy
Carnage and so in the midst of all of
this and because all these Venom
symbiotes are weak to fire he conjures
the hellmark manifests a boatload of
Hellfire in order to keep them at Bay
and then uses it as a distraction to
start taking out these different
characters then he targets virus and
what we end up finding out here is that
virus is actually Dylan Brock from the
earth 1051 Universe the guy that
basically became a villain and then took
over the entirety of Earth only to
change his ways and go back to being a
good guy he's a little kid inside the
suit of armor and everybody's kind of
shocked and surprised at the fact that
like Andy would bring him to this
conflict in the first place but in
reality here like she really cares more
about the life of Dylan her biological
son than anybody else so she like
immediately goes to rescue her son and
then of course treating it as a kind of
distraction anti-venom in everybody ends
up stepping in they do momentarily get
the upper hand on Carnage but then he
just absorbs them all into himself
everybody except for screen right
everybody except for Andy Benton the
kicker about all this like I said is we
don't know what would happen if a
Carnage symbiote with no host absorbed
an Anti-Venom and so literally these
guys are bursting out of him but this is
only three issues in so I have to
believe this was actually one of the
worst choices they could have made by
allowing him to absorb anti-venom
because now it means he can literally
just touch a Venom symbiote strip them
of their abilities take their codex and
walk away it actually makes it
infinitely easier for him to do what
he's been doing so far with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end if you guys need to get caught up
on Carnage make sure you guys click this
link to the playlist and I will catch
you all later peace